When I talked to Scharlette Holdman, she'd spent 35 years working with defense teams on death penalty cases, including a very high-profile cases. But she hadn't given an interview to the press in decades, ever since an incident where she had a few drinks with a reporter, and said some things she was unhappy to see in print.
当我与夏洛特·霍尔德曼（Scharlette Holdman）交谈时，她已经在死刑案件的辩护团队中工作了35年，其中包括一些备受瞩目的案件。但几十年来，她一直没有接受过媒体采访，起因是一次她与一名记者喝了几杯酒，说了一些她事后很不希望见报的话。
And it was so embarrassing. And I thought, well, I either have to quit drinking or quit doing interviews. And I wasn't ready to quit drinking yet. So I quit doing interviews.
那太令人尴尬了。我想，要么我得戒酒，要么我得停止接受采访。而当时我还没准备好戒酒。所以我停止了接受采访。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So this interview is a very rare event for me. I haven't done any kind of interviews with the media since '85.
所以这次采访对我来说是一件非常罕见的事情。自85年以来，我没有接受过任何媒体的采访。
And you are ending the moratorium in this one instance, for this story, why?
你这次打破沉默，专门为了这个故事，为什么？
Well, a fluffy, red-combed leghorn deserves his moment in the sun-- just the image. And I'm not talking about any chicken. I'm talking about-- you can just picture it, this beautiful Leghorn, his tail perked up, and that red comb, sitting at a rakish angle on his head, and his head cocked to the side. And he looks at you with his little eyes. That's what this story is about.
嗯，一只毛茸茸的、长着红鸡冠的来航鸡值得拥有属于它的高光时刻——仅仅是这个形象。我说的不是普通的鸡。我说的是——你可以想象一下，那只美丽的来航鸡，尾巴翘着，红红的鸡冠以一种时髦的角度斜在头上，脑袋歪向一边。它用小眼睛看着你。这就是这个故事的主题。
That is not just what this story is about. That is what a lot of today's radio show is about. Back in the early days of our radio show, once a year, during the highest poultry consumption time in the country, which is, of course-- if you about this for a second, you can guess the answer to this. It's the weeks that begin with Thanksgiving, and go through Christmas and New Year's.
这不仅仅是这个故事的主题。这也是今天广播节目很大一部分的主题。在我们广播节目早期的日子里，每年一次，在全国禽肉消费最高的时候，当然是——如果你稍微想一下，就能猜到答案。就是从感恩节开始，一直到圣诞节和新年的那几周。
Anyway, during that period, for years on our show, we had a tradition here, where we would devote an entire hour of our program to stories of chickens, turkeys, ducks, fowl of all kind. In an homage to Chicago's poetry slams, which were spread across the country, but were created at the Green Mill Bar on the North side by poet Marc Smith, we named these programs "poultry" slams-- poultry.
总之，在那段时间里，多年来我们节目有一个传统，我们会用整整一个小时的节目来讲关于鸡、火鸡、鸭子和各种禽类的故事。为了向芝加哥的诗歌朗诵比赛（poetry slams）致敬，这种比赛虽然遍布全国，但最初是由诗人马克·史密斯（Marc Smith）在北区的“绿色磨坊酒吧”（Green Mill Bar）创立的，我们把这些节目命名为“家禽”朗诵比赛（poultry slams）——家禽。
But I just want to be clear, before we begin, the word "slam," we are using that with no malice toward any bird of any kind at all. No birds were hurt, no birds were slaughtered, no birds were slammed in the making of today's program. And we have incredible stories today, incredible enough that at least one woman has ended a quarter-century moratorium on talking to the press to be here with me. And you should too. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
但在我们开始之前，我想明确一点，“slam”这个词，我们用它绝对没有任何针对任何鸟类的恶意。在制作今天的节目过程中，没有任何鸟类受到伤害，没有鸟类被宰杀，也没有鸟类被“重击”。今天我们有不可思议的故事，不可思议到至少有一位女士结束了长达四分之一个世纪的媒体禁令来到这里和我交谈。你也应该留下来。这里是WBEZ芝加哥的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act one, Witness for the Barbicue-tion. Scharlette Holdman didn't just get the idea of calling a chicken as a witness in a murder case out of the blue. She was working on this case-- and we're going to call this guy Harry-- and there was no question that the guy had killed somebody. This wasn't about whether he'd done it. It was about what sentence he would get.
第一幕，烧烤案的证人。夏洛特·霍尔德曼并不是凭空想出在谋杀案中传唤一只鸡作为证人的主意。她当时正在处理这起案件——我们就叫这个家伙哈里（Harry）吧——毫无疑问这个家伙杀了人。这不是关于他是否做了这件事。而是关于他会得到什么样的判决。
He had sat on death row at San Quentin for 10 years. But Scharlette says he was schizophrenic, with an IQ of 58, and just out of touch with reality.
他在圣昆廷监狱的死囚牢房里坐了10年。但夏洛特说他患有精神分裂症，智商只有58，完全脱离了现实。
And one of the things he did-- he wrote messages and symbols on little pieces of toilet paper, and rolled them up in a ball-- and had done this for years on death row-- rolled the little secret messages up in a ball, and then rolled them in feces, his own feces, into little, tiny, bead-sized balls, and put those into the braids in his hair--
他做过的事情之一——他把信息和符号写在小块卫生纸上，揉成球——在死囚牢房里他多年来一直这么做——把秘密信息揉成球，然后裹上粪便，他自己的粪便，搓成小小的、珠子大小的球，放进他头发的辫子里——
Oh, my.
哦，天哪。
--so that they dangled around his forehead.
——让它们垂在他的前额周围。
And the things he was putting in his hair, from his point of view, were they communicating some information, the little messages?
那么他头发里放的那些东西，从他的角度来看，是在传达某种信息吗？
Exactly. But he couldn't tell me what the messages were because they were secret. When I would talk to him about his mother, he would tell me she lived in a Coca-Cola can.
正是如此。但他无法告诉我这些信息是什么，因为它们是秘密。当我和他谈论他母亲时，他会告诉我她住在一个可口可乐罐子里。
It's against the law to execute somebody who is so crazy he doesn't understand why he's being executed. And Scharlette said that was true for this guy.
法律规定禁止处决一个疯到连自己为何被处决都不明白的人。夏洛特说这对这个家伙来说是真的。
When I would say, do you know what's going to happen on the 12th of June, he was befuddled. And with pressure, he would finally say, well, yeah, he thought he was going to be re-upholstered.
当我说，你知道6月12日会发生什么吗，他感到困惑。在压力下，他最终会说，嗯，是的，他以为他要被“重新装修”了。
The state of California did not agree with Scharlette about this guy. They wanted to execute him in 30 days. Scharlette's team was making a last-ditch appeal to stay this execution. Meanwhile, the state was gathering its evidence.
加利福尼亚州不同意夏洛特关于这个人的看法。他们想在30天内处决他。夏洛特的团队正在做最后的上诉以暂缓执行。与此同时，州政府正在收集证据。
San Quentin sent in a prison psychiatrist to determine, was he competent to be executed? Did he know he was going to be executed? And did he know why he was going to be executed? So the psychiatrist goes and interviews Harry.
圣昆廷监狱派来了一名监狱精神科医生来确定他是否有能力接受处决？他知道自己会被处决吗？他知道自己为什么会被处决吗？于是精神科医生去采访了哈里。
And then the psychiatrist testified in court that not only was Harry aware that he was going to be executed, she was so certain of this because she had played tic-tac-toe with him and Harry had beat her.
然后精神科医生在法庭上作证说，哈里不仅知道自己会被处决，她之所以如此肯定，是因为她曾和哈里玩过井字棋，而且哈里赢了她。
Well, it was so absurd and so outside of any normal experience in a courtroom-- and this was after 30 years of being in death penalty cases in the South, around the world. And I really couldn't believe she had said it. But at the same time, the only image that came to me-- I'm from the South, obviously.
嗯，这太荒谬了，完全超出了法庭上的任何正常经验——这是在我从事了30年的南方乃至世界各地的死刑案件之后。我真的不敢相信她竟然说了出来。但与此同时，我脑海中出现的唯一形象——显然我是南方人。
And growing up, we always went to the Mid-South Fair. And they had a chicken that played tic-tac-toe, that absolutely mesmerized me. And it was pretty clear to me, OK, we've got to find a chicken who can play tic-tac-toe.
从小到大，我们总是去中南博览会。他们有一只会玩井字棋的鸡，那完全让我着迷。对我来说很清楚，好吧，我们得找到一只会玩井字棋的鸡。
Scharlette thought-- and this is not a joke. It's not an exaggeration-- she thought that a chicken like that could save this man's life. Jurors, after all, tend to believe the state and its witnesses. And a chicken like that could totally undermine the psychiatrist's testimony, by proving that playing tic-tac-toe doesn't mean that you understand things like why you're being executed.
夏洛特认为——这不是玩笑，也不是夸张——她认为那样一只鸡可以拯救这个人的生命。毕竟，陪审团倾向于相信州政府及其证人。而那样一只鸡可以完全削弱精神科医生的证词，证明会玩井字棋并不意味着你明白为什么要被处决之类的事情。
I just knew a chicken would work. It's a sad state. But I think a chicken has more credibility than the defense team did. And I think it would have brought the jury over to seeing us as people, rather than as these obstructionists, who were interfering with an execution. And who can doubt a chicken? Chickens aren't going to lie. Chickens have integrity.
我只是知道鸡会管用。这是一个悲哀的状态。但我认为鸡比辩护团队更有可信度。我认为它会让陪审团把我们看作是人，而不是那些干扰死刑执行的阻碍者。谁会怀疑一只鸡呢？鸡是不会撒谎的。鸡有诚信。
I had this image of the psychiatrist being on the stand. And I would quietly enter through the wooden doors, as they opened, with this beautiful Leghorn under my arm, and the comb at a rakish angle.
我脑海中浮现出精神科医生站在证人席上的画面。我会悄悄地穿过打开的木门，怀里抱着这只美丽的来航鸡，鸡冠斜挂着。
And as I walked into the courtroom, not saying a word, and quietly took a seat on the front row, the psychiatrist, who we knew because we had investigated her background from New York City, would see a person with a chicken and think, why is that-- oh, my god, no. And that psychiatrist would slowly realize that she was going to have to play tic-tac-toe with a chicken.
当我走进法庭，一言不发，安静地在第一排坐下时，那位我们因为调查过她在纽约市的背景而了解的精神科医生，会看到一个抱着鸡的人，心想，为什么那个——哦，天哪，不。那位精神科医生会慢慢意识到她将不得不和一只鸡玩井字棋。
So you're trying to psych out-- you were trying to get inside the psychiatrist's head--
所以你是想搞心理战——你是想进入精神科医生的脑子里——
Exactly.
正是如此。
--and make the psychiatrist unravel even before you pull your stunt.
——并在你真的使出这一招之前就让精神科医生崩溃。
The jury's eyes as awareness overcame her. So it wouldn't work with the frazzled chicken. I didn't want to splotchy, beat-up, tired, exhausted chicken. I wanted a chicken that could capture the audience's attention. In this case, the audience was the jury.
当她意识到这一点时陪审团的眼神。所以它不能用那只疲惫的鸡。我不想要一只斑驳、破旧、疲惫、精疲力竭的鸡。我想要一只能够抓住观众注意力的鸡。在这种情况下，观众就是陪审团。
Right. You needed a chicken like in a cartoon.
对。你需要一只像卡通片里那样的鸡。
I had to have a chicken that could take on a psychiatrist. It had to be a stand-up chicken.
我必须有一只能对抗精神科医生的鸡。它必须是一只会站立的鸡。
Noted.
记下了。
So we began to hunt for this stand-up chicken.
所以我们开始寻找这只会站立的鸡。
Well, this task fell to the legal interns. A man was scheduled to die, at that point, in less than two weeks. And they needed a chicken. And they searched the places that you find tic-tac-toe playing chickens, namely county fairs, carnivals. And really, within hours, they found a tic-tac-toe playing goose in Montana. But of course, Scharlette says that was totally unacceptable.
嗯，这项任务落在了法律实习生身上。当时那个男人预计将在不到两周内被处死。他们需要一只鸡。他们搜寻了那些能找到会玩井字棋的鸡的地方，即乡村集市、嘉年华。真的，在几个小时内，他们在蒙大拿州找到了一只会玩井字棋的鹅。但当然，夏洛特说这完全不可接受。
Geese are nasty. They bite you. And I didn't want a goose running around the courtroom, chasing someone.
鹅很讨厌。它们会咬人。我不想让一只鹅在法庭上跑来跑去，追逐某人。
Next was a guy at a roadside stand in Wyoming who did have a chicken. And it did play tic-tac-toe. But he said that flying or driving it to California for the trial would probably upset it so much that he could not guarantee that it would win the game of tic-tac-toe. So he was out.
下一个是怀俄明州路边摊的一个人，他确实有一只鸡。而且它确实会玩井字棋。但他表示，为了审判把它空运或开车运到加利福尼亚州可能会让它感到非常不安，以至于他不能保证它能赢下井字棋游戏。所以他出局了。
Finally, they found a fellow in Arkansas who trains chickens to play tic-tac-toe. And he had a whole list of chickens that he had trained around the country. And he sent the legal team to one of those birds, in San Francisco. That turned out to be a dead end. San Francisco had actually passed an ordinance banning the playing of tic-tac-toe by chickens, as animal cruelty. Fortunately, another chicken on the list was not far from there, at the boardwalk in Santa Cruz. They had their chicken.
最后，他们在阿肯色州发现了一个训练鸡玩井字棋的人。他有一长串在全国各地受过训练的鸡。他把法律团队派往旧金山去找其中的一只鸟。结果是个死胡同。旧金山实际上已经通过了一项法令，禁止鸡玩井字棋，将其视为虐待动物。幸运的是，名单上的另一只鸡离那里不远，在圣克鲁斯的木板路上。他们找到了他们的鸡。
So the next step was to convince the Court to let us bring the chicken to court as a witness, as demonstrative evidence, to introduce the chicken, and let the chicken play tic-tac-toe. Now of course, I wanted the chicken to play tic-tac-toe with the psychiatrist. But I realized--
所以下一步是说服法庭允许我们把鸡带到法庭作为证人，作为演示证据，介绍这只鸡，并让它玩井字棋。当然，我希望鸡能和精神科医生玩井字棋。但我意识到——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--yeah, that most likely, no one was going to let us get away with that. But I did think that any of us, a really healthy group of interns. They knew how to play tic-tac-toe-- so that we could demonstrate to the jury that playing tic-tac-toe did not mean that you were aware of the consequences of your actions.
——是的，很可能没人会让我们得逞。但我确实认为我们中的任何一个，一群非常健康的实习生。他们知道怎么玩井字棋——这样我们可以向陪审团证明，会玩井字棋并不意味着你了解自己行为的后果。
Why wouldn't you be allowed to make the psychiatrist play tic-tac-toe with a chicken? I understand why the psychiatrist would not want to do it. But from a legal point of view, what line does that cross?
为什么不允许让精神科医生和鸡玩井字棋呢？我明白为什么精神科医生不想这样做。但从法律角度来看，这越过了什么界限？
Well, evidently-- I agree with you. But the Court felt-- it never addressed the issue of having to play the psychiatrist-- but the Court felt that bringing the chicken into the courtroom to play tic-tac-toe would degrade the dignity of the Court.
嗯，显然——我同意你的看法。但法庭认为——它从未处理过必须和精神科医生玩的问题——但法庭认为把鸡带进法庭玩井字棋会损害法庭的尊严。
I thought that the dignity of the Court was degraded by executing a mentally-ill person. So the Court denied our motion and said we could not bring the chicken into the courtroom for demonstrative evidence. It ruled against us.
我认为处决一个精神病患者才会损害法庭的尊严。所以法庭驳回了我们的动议，说我们不能把鸡带进法庭作为演示证据。它做出了对我们不利的裁决。
They weren't even allowed to show the jury a video of the chicken playing tic-tac-toe. And without a chicken on the stand, without a video of a chicken, the jury found the psychiatrist credible, and ruled to execute Scharlette's client. His life was saved, later, on appeal. And in the years since then, in 2002, the Supreme Court ruled that a person at his level of mental retardation cannot be executed.
他们甚至不允许向陪审团展示鸡玩井字棋的视频。在没有鸡在证人席上，没有鸡的视频的情况下，陪审团认为精神科医生是可信的，并裁定处决夏洛特的委托人。后来，他的生命在上诉中得到了挽救。自那以后的几年里，在2002年，最高法院裁定，智力处于这种水平的人不能被处决。
For Scharlette, though, the story stays with her, the story of the chicken, because in decades of doing these capital trials, bringing hundreds of witnesses, it is the greatest courtroom move she ever invented, bringing in the chicken. And she never got to try it. She invented this thing. She never got to try it. It was snatched away from her. Something like that sticks in your craw.
但对夏洛特来说，这个故事一直伴随着她，关于鸡的故事，因为在几十年的资本案件审判中，带过数百名证人，这是她发明过的最伟大的法庭动作，把鸡带进来。但她从来没有机会尝试。她发明了这个东西。她从来没能试过。它从她手中被夺走了。像这样的事情会一直卡在你的喉咙里。
Well, yeah, because I didn't get to do it. But it's also because of the nature and quality of a chicken. When you do this kind of work, when you're down in the worst part-- when you're trying to work for folks that literally, the community wants to kill, it can be pretty discouraging.
嗯，是的，因为我没能做到。但这也有关鸡的本性和品质。当你从事这种工作时，当你身处最糟糕的部分——当你试图为那些字面上社区想要杀掉的人工作时，这可能会非常令人沮丧。
But you have this nice, fluffy Leghorn, brightens up your day-- for John. And all of this-- all of this is not to make light of death as punishment, of people with mental retardation, of people who are mentally ill, or of chickens.
但你有一只可爱的、毛茸茸的来航鸡，让你的日子变得光明——为了约翰。这一切——这一切并不是要轻视死刑、智障人士、精神病患者或鸡。
Thank you for saying that.
谢谢你这么说。
Yeah. And no, it's really not. I actually am a member of PETA.
是的。不，真的不是。我其实是善待动物组织（PETA）的成员。
Scharlette Holdman in New Orleans. Today's show is a rerun. We first broadcast this story back in 2011. In the years since, capital punishment was suspended in the state of California by Governor Gavin Newsom. Scharlette, this incredible person that I loved talking to, she was called the Angel of Death Row for her work in getting proper legal representation for people on death row. She died in 2017.
新奥尔良的夏洛特·霍尔德曼。今天的节目是重播。我们最早在2011年播出了这个故事。自那以后的几年里，加利福尼亚州州长加文·纽森（Gavin Newsom）暂停了死刑。夏洛特，这位我非常喜欢与之交谈的不可思议的人，因为她为死囚争取适当法律代表的工作而被誉为“死囚天使”。她于2017年去世。
Act two, Chicken Diva. Chickens are what we make of them, in lots of ways. If you could possibly need further evidence of that, after that first act, we have this story from Jack Hitt.
第二幕，鸡之女主角。在很多方面，鸡是我们对它们的理解。如果你在第一幕之后还需要进一步证明这一点，我们有杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）带来的这个故事。
Oddly enough, it wasn't Susan who was obsessed with chickens. It was Kenny, a pal who worked backstage at the 92nd Street Y in New York. His house was filled with chicken cups, chicken masks. He got the whole staff onto chickens, including Susan. For a time there, in the '80s, poultry-related jokes and references became the fast way to get a laugh at the Y.
奇怪的是，痴迷于鸡的人并不是苏珊（Susan）。是肯尼（Kenny），一个在纽约第92街Y中心后台工作的朋友。他的房子里到处都是鸡杯、鸡面具。他让整个员工都迷上了鸡，包括苏珊。在80年代的那段时间里，与禽类相关的笑话和引用成了在Y中心博取笑声的快速方式。
I guess most of us are condemned to see nothing more than the easy comedy of chickens. But Susan Vitucci saw something else, their potential greatness, their hidden beauty, their grandeur. One day she glued together some finger puppets for a 10-minute rendition of the Chicken Little story for her nephew. That was 14 years ago.
我想我们大多数人都注定只能看到鸡的简单喜剧一面。但苏珊·维图奇（Susan Vitucci）看到了别的东西，它们的潜在伟大、隐藏的美丽、宏伟。有一天，她为她的侄子把一些手指木偶粘在一起，排演了10分钟的《小鸡快跑》（Chicken Little）故事。那是14年前的事了。
Today, it is a full-length opera, enjoyed by a cult following whenever it goes up in a workshop or cafe or small theater. It's still performed with finger puppets. But now it has a complete score, written by a noted composer, Henry Krieger, who did Dreamgirls. The Chicken Little opera he wrote with Susan Vitucci is called Love's Fowl. Needless to say, that's F-O-W-L.
今天，它是一部完整的歌剧，每当它在工作坊、咖啡馆或小剧院上演时，都会受到狂热追随者的喜爱。它仍然是用手指木偶表演的。但现在它有了完整的配乐，由著名作曲家亨利·克里格（Henry Krieger）创作，他曾为《梦幻女郎》（Dreamgirls）作曲。他和苏珊·维图奇创作的《小鸡快跑》歌剧名为《爱的家禽》（Love's Fowl）。不用说，那是F-O-W-L（家禽，与“犯规”同音）。
Well, we were going to start with the opening, [NON-ENGLISH]. We are the Clothespin Repertory Theater. And we have a special singing guest for you, which I don't know--
嗯，我们本来要从开场开始，[意大利语]。我们是晾衣夹剧团（Clothespin Repertory Theater）。我们有一位特别的演唱嘉宾为你准备，我不知道——
Susan and I are sitting at Henry's baby grand piano. Henry's guest is his Maltese terrier, named Toby.
苏珊和我坐在亨利的平台三角钢琴旁。亨利的客人是他的马耳他梗，名叫托比（Toby）。
Perhaps Toby would be kind enough to join me--
也许托比愿意加入我——
Yeah, would he sit on your lap for this?
是的，他会坐在你腿上做这个吗？
--at the piano. Yeah, let's see what we can do.
——在钢琴旁。是的，让我们看看能做什么。
OK.
好的。
OK, listen carefully because once Toby gets going, he actually harmonizes with Henry and Susan
好的，仔细听，因为一旦托比开始，他实际上会和亨利与苏珊和声。
[MUSIC - HENRY KRIEGER AND SUSAN VITUCCI SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[音乐 - 亨利·克里格和苏珊·维图奇用意大利语演唱]
[DOG WHINING AND HOWLING TO MUSIC]
[狗对音乐发出呜呜声和嚎叫声]
You may have noticed that this libretto is in Italian, just like a real opera.
你可能已经注意到，这部剧本是用意大利语写的，就像真正的歌剧一样。
Before, it was just a bunch of puppets in a box, with a good idea. And then suddenly, as soon as it went into Italian, it became something bigger than what it had been. And it's because when it's in English, we all know it. And it's really not that interesting. And it's like, yeah, yeah, yeah. As soon as it's in Italian, it gives us enough distance that we can come in.
以前，它只是一堆盒子里的木偶，带有一个好点子。然后突然间，一旦它变成了意大利语，它就变得比以前更宏大了。这是因为当它是英语时，我们都懂。它真的没那么有趣。就像，是是是。一旦它是意大利语，它就给了我们足够的距离，让我们能进入它。
It makes us-- it's like the lover who doesn't want you. You don't want anybody more than you want the one who doesn't want you. Right? And so it's the same thing.
它让我们——就像那个不想要你的爱人。你不想要任何人超过你想要那个不想要你的人。对吧？所以这是一样的。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
You may recall that when you last heard of Little, back in kindergarten, she was just an average barn-door fowl, who had an acorn drop on her head, which she mistakenly understood to be the sky falling. Her alarms excited her friends, Goosey Loosey, Turkey Lurkey, and Ducky Lucky. And they join her for a journey to the king, to tell him the important news.
你可能还记得当你最后一次在幼儿园听说小鸡快跑时，她只是一只普通的农场家禽，头上掉了一颗橡子，她错误地理解为天要塌下来了。她的警报让她的朋友们兴奋起来：鹅西露西（Goosey Loosey）、火鸡路基（Turkey Lurkey）和鸭子卢基（Ducky Lucky）。他们加入她前往国王那里，告诉他这个重要消息。
On the way, they meet up with Sly Fox. Little's pals eagerly accept his invitation for dinner, literally as it turns out. Fortunately for Little, hunger is not enough to distract her from her mission. And she tracks on. When she meets the king, he tells her that the sky is not falling. It's just an acorn. So the enlightened Chicken Little returns to her coop. And that's where the story ends.
在路上，他们遇到了狡猾的狐狸。小鸡快跑的朋友们欣然接受了他的晚餐邀请，结果真的是晚餐。幸运的是对于小鸡快跑来说，饥饿不足以让她分心于任务。她继续前进。当她见到国王时，他告诉她天没有塌下来。那只是一颗橡子。于是开明的小鸡快跑回到了她的鸡舍。故事就结束在那里。
What are we to take away from Little's experience? I'd like to think it's that Little is rewarded with life, precisely because she went off on this quixotic mission, totally in the grip of a wrong idea.
我们要从小鸡快跑的经历中学到什么？我愿意认为，小鸡快跑被奖励了生命，正是因为她进行了这次堂吉诃德式的任务，完全沉浸在一个错误的想法中。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
The children's fable barely figures into the story. It's just one small episode in the life of Chicken Little, now known as La Pulcina Piccola. After the acorn incident, she goes on to become an internationally renowned figure in almost every field imaginable, a diva of politics, academe, theater, art, daring-do.
儿童寓言在故事中几乎没有占据位置。这只是小鸡快跑生活中的一个小插曲，现在被称为拉·普尔奇娜·皮科拉（La Pulcina Piccola）。橡子事件后，她继续成为几乎所有可想象领域中享誉国际的人物，政治、学术、戏剧、艺术、勇敢的歌剧女主角。
Like Venus, she arrives from some other world, transported on a scallop shell. But the triumphs of her life began after a youthful love affair with a fighting cock ends bitterly. And she consoles herself, as we all do at some point in our lives, by plunging into Shakespeare. She becomes an overnight sensation as an actress, celebrated all over the world for one role, Juliet, Cleopatra, Ophelia?
像维纳斯一样，她来自另一个世界，坐着扇贝壳而来。但她生活的胜利始于一场年轻的爱情与一只斗鸡痛苦结束之后。她安慰自己，就像我们生活中的某个时刻一样，通过沉浸在莎士比亚作品中。她一夜之间成为了一名演员，因一个角色而闻名世界，朱丽叶、克利奥帕特拉、奥菲利亚？
The company, then, performs an excerpt-- a recreation of her signature role, which was Richard III. Well, Sarah Bernhardt did Hamlet.
于是公司表演了一个片段——重现了她的招牌角色，那是《理查三世》（Richard III）。嗯，莎拉·伯恩哈特（Sarah Bernhardt）演过哈姆雷特。
Well, there's a great tradition of women playing the men's roles in Shakespeare. But I think Richard III is one of the more rare roles to be played by a woman.
嗯，女性扮演莎士比亚男性角色有伟大的传统。但我认为《理查三世》是女性扮演的比较罕见的角色之一。
Well, that's how adventuresome an actress this chicken was.
嗯，这就是这只鸡作为演员的冒险精神。
I can assure you, there is nothing like watching a 4-inch tall finger puppet crying out, "a horse, a horse, my kingdom for a horse" in Italian. Not to mention that puppet is a chicken, surrounded by a whole supporting cast of poultry and other avian supernumeraries. Susan says that artistically, there's something special about chickens.
我可以向你保证，没有什么比看着一个4英寸高的人偶木偶在意大利语中尖叫“一匹马，一匹马，我的王国换一匹马”更像了。更不用说那个木偶是一只鸡，被一群由家禽和其他鸟类配角组成的整个支持阵容所包围。苏珊说，在艺术上，鸡有什么特别之处。
They're a clean slate. You can put anything on them. You can project anything onto them because it's not like they have, to me at least, a very strong personality.
它们是一张白纸。你可以在它们身上放任何东西。你可以把任何东西投射到它们身上，因为在我看来，它们并没有非常强烈的个性。
Except for La Pulchina. In the opera, she moves into the field of archaeology, masters it, needless to say, and makes a great discovery, the last tomb of Gallapatra, but not before she sails the seven seas, is shipwrecked, gets rescued, but it's by pirates, and then she meets the pirate king.
除了拉·普尔奇娜。在歌剧中，她进入了考古学领域，不用说，精通了它，并做出了伟大的发现，加拉帕特拉（Gallapatra）的最后墓穴，但在她航行七大洋、遭遇海难、获救（是被海盗救的）以及见到海盗王之前，并没有发生。
As soon as he meets her, he falls in love with her because of her sweet spirit-- because she comes in and she says, here you see a little chicken who, although I'm dripping wet, I'm proud and yellow.
她一见到她就爱上了她，因为她甜美的精神——因为她走进去说，在这里你可以看到一只小鸡，虽然我湿透了，但我自豪而且是黄色的。
Let me repeat that lyric for you in a pure translation. "Although I stand before you a chicken who is dripping wet, I am proud. And I am yellow." OK, back to Susan.
让我用纯翻译为你重复那句歌词。“虽然我站在你面前是一只湿透的鸡，但我很自豪。我是黄色的。”好的，回到苏珊。
And although I've loved and I have lost, I have learned to follow the call of adventure. So let's sail on.
虽然我爱过也失去过，但我已经学会了追随冒险的召唤。让我们起航吧。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
Keep in mind that all of the action, like everything that occurs in every Susan Vitucci production, ever since the first one for her nephew, and continuing to this day, occurs among characters created by sticking a small, painted Styrofoam ball onto a larger painted Styrofoam ball, poking in two map tacks for eyes, gluing on a tiny felt beak, and then impaling the whole thing on top of one of those really old fashioned clothespins that a '40s cartoon figure would clamp to his nose around a chunk of Limburger cheese.
请记住，所有的动作，就像苏珊·维图奇每一部作品中发生的每件事一样，从第一次为她侄子表演开始，一直持续到今天，都发生在通过将一个小的、彩绘的泡沫球粘在一个更大的彩绘泡沫球上创造的角色之间，戳入两个地图图钉作为眼睛，粘上一个小毛毡喙，然后把整个东西插在一根那些老式的晾衣夹顶端上，那是40年代卡通人物会夹在鼻子上吃林堡干酪的那种。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
And I could go on. Susan has written, or as she puts it, translated La Pulcina Piccola's diaries, which detail the other adventures that happen in between those in the opera. There are 60 pages so far, excerpts of which have appeared in Clotheslines, the official fan-club newsletter of the opera. Love's Fowl has a strange effect on people.
我还可以继续说下去。苏珊写了，或者正如她所说的，翻译了拉·普尔奇娜·皮科拉的日记，详细记载了歌剧中发生的其他冒险。目前已经有60页了，摘录出现在歌剧的官方粉丝俱乐部通讯《晾衣绳》（Clotheslines）中。《爱的家禽》对人有一种奇怪的影响。
I didn't understand it until Susan loaned me a videotape of one performance. To be honest, I thought I would be annoyed at the intentional irony and hokiness of the puppets. But there I was, with my three-year-old daughter, who loved the show, watching a plastic bird pantomime one of the simplest human moments, but also one of the most profound, the confession of a great love, in this case, with a Cock Robin.
我没明白，直到苏珊借给我一盘演出的录像带。老实说，我以为我会对木偶故意的讽刺和俗气感到恼火。但我当时和我三岁的女儿在一起，她喜欢这个表演，看着一只塑料鸟模仿人类最简单但也最深刻的时刻之一，表达伟大的爱，在这种情况下，与一只知更鸟（Cock Robin）。
The song that she sings as she enters goes, "I am a chicken and ready for love. My heart is as fragile as the egg from which I was born. Treat me gently, and so will I treat you. Together, from earthly love, we will reach for the divine." And then she sings, "I'm a chicken and I can't fly without love. My heart, it is strong as the egg from which I was born," and so forth. And so it is only with Cock Robin that she flies.
她登场时唱的歌是，“我是一只鸡，准备好去爱。我的心像我出生时的蛋一样脆弱。温柔地对待我，我也会同样对待你。在一起，从世俗的爱中，我们将触及神圣。”然后她唱道，“我是一只鸡，没有爱我就无法飞翔。我的心，像我出生时的蛋一样坚强，”等等。所以只有和知更鸟在一起，她才能飞翔。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
And after they have agreed to fly together and they are soaring in the air, Cock Robin is shot and killed, murdered by a jealous sparrow. I couldn't believe it, but I was getting choked up, especially when Cock Robin appeared on the stage, his Styrofoam body spray painted black for the lament, his little magic-marker eyes drawn as X's.
在他们同意一起飞翔并且正在空中翱翔之后，知更鸟被射杀了，被一只嫉妒的麻雀谋杀了。我不敢相信，但我哽咽了，特别是当知更鸟出现在舞台上时，他的泡沫身体为了哀歌被喷成了黑色，他的小马克笔眼睛画成了X。
I gathered my daughter my arms and held on tight, as I was helplessly drawn into an expression of the grief and suffering of this little sad bird. In this era of slick special effects, there was something unexpectedly liberating in the marriage of this crude medium, painted Styrofoam balls bobbing up and down behind a cardboard box, and the high, melodramatic art of Italian opera. Picture it.
我把女儿搂在怀里紧紧抱着，因为我无助地陷入了这只忧伤的小鸟对悲伤和痛苦的表达。在这个时髦特效的时代，这种原始媒介——在纸板箱后面上下浮动的彩绘泡沫球——与意大利歌剧高亢、夸张的艺术的结合，有一种意想不到的解放感。想象一下。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
I want a subscription to that newsletter. Are you going to do this-- I mean, are you going to be working with Pulcina Piccola, you think, for the rest of your life?
我想要订阅那个通讯。你打算做这个——我的意思是，你认为你会和普尔奇娜·皮科拉一起工作余生吗？
It's possible. And I like working with her because I get to go into a world that's inhabited by a very sweet spirit, and play with the mechanics of the world. And because it's very small-- I could never have afforded to produce this show with people. But I could afford to do it with clothespins.
有可能。我喜欢和她一起工作，因为我可以进入一个由非常甜美的精神居住的世界，并与这个世界的机制一起玩耍。而且因为它非常小——我永远负担不起用真人来制作这个表演。但我负担得起用晾衣夹来做。
So I can do as big a production as I want with clothespins. I can have stuff fly in and out and come in from traps. And I can have all kinds of fancy, flashy stuff that costs millions of dollars to do on Broadway. And it cost me $200 because I had to buy lots and lots and lots of Styrofoam and clothespins and stuff and all this, and a new table maybe, and I get to do whatever I want.
所以我可以用晾衣夹做我想做的任何规模的作品。我可以让东西飞进飞出，从活板门进来。我可以拥有各种百老汇花数百万美元才能做的花哨、华丽的东西。而我只花了200美元，因为我不得不买很多很多泡沫、晾衣夹之类的东西，还有一张新桌子，我可以做任何我想做的事。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
That story from Jack Hitt.
那是杰克·希特带来的故事。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
Coming up, chicken supermodels and chickens who return with a message from the afterlife. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，鸡模特和从彼岸带回信息的鸡。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, during this period of greatest poultry consumption in our nation, the weeks between Thanksgiving and Christmas, we bring you stories of chickens, turkeys, ducks, fowl of all kind, real and imagined.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，带给你各种关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，在我们国家禽肉消费最高的这段时间，感恩节和圣诞节之间的几周，我们带给你关于鸡、火鸡、鸭子、各种禽类的故事，真实的和想象的。
We arrived at Act three, of our program, Act Three, Trying to Respect the Chicken.
我们来到了节目的第三幕，第三幕，试图尊重鸡。
OK, sure, it's one thing to take a fictional character like Chicken Little and make her into a star. Try doing that with a real chicken. Seriously, just try.
好的，当然，把像小鸡快跑这样的虚构角色变成明星是一回事。尝试用一只真正的鸡来做这件事。认真地说，试一试吧。
Well, these are photographs of chickens. The first one here is a silver-laced Wyandotte. It's a black-and-white bird, essentially, but the tail feathers have a lot of iridescent green coloring.
嗯，这些是鸡的照片。这里的第一张是银纹怀恩多特鸡（silver-laced Wyandotte）。它本质上是一只黑白相间的鸟，但尾羽有很多彩虹色的绿色。
In a world where chickens get no respect, Tamara Staples treats him the way that humans treat those we revere most. She takes their portraits, lovingly. Her shots are like fashion photographs, beautifully lit, color backdrops. They're beautiful.
在一个鸡得不到任何尊重的世界里，塔玛拉·斯台普斯（Tamara Staples）以我们最崇敬人类的方式对待它。她充满爱意地给它们拍肖像。她的作品就像时尚摄影，打光精美，彩色背景。它们很美。
See, that first one looked regal. But now you've just turned to one where it almost looks like it's like a clown. It looks comic.
看，第一张看起来很威严。但现在你刚转到一张它看起来几乎像小丑的照片。它看起来很滑稽。
Mm-hmm. It's a mottled Houdan, which I always called the Phyllis Diller chicken, which is--
嗯。这是一只斑点胡丹鸡（mottled Houdan），我总是称之为菲利斯·迪勒（Phyllis Diller）鸡，也就是——
Oh, my god, the chicken does look like Phyllis Diller.
哦，天哪，这只鸡看起来确实像菲利斯·迪勒。
It does. It's the hat. It looks like-- it's got this huge, feathered hat sort of thing and a strange body shape and these--
确实。就是那顶帽子。它看起来就像——它有这种巨大的、羽毛状的帽子，奇怪的体型和这些——
In a way it's like Tamara Staples is running an odd little cross-species science experiment, one that asks this question, what happens when you try to treat a chicken the way we treat humans, even if it's just for the length of a photo shoot? What happens, it turns out, is that you learn just where the thin line is that divides human beings from birds.
在某种程度上，就像塔玛拉·斯台普斯在进行一项奇怪的跨物种科学实验，一个提出了这个问题的问题：当你尝试像对待人类一样对待鸡时会发生什么，即使只是在拍照的时间里？事实证明，你会学到区分人类和鸟类的那条细线在哪里。
All right, maybe it's not such a thin line. But it's definitely a line. And like most city people, I had never thought about it, about where it lays, about what it might be, what it might consist of, until Tamara and I headed out to a farm.
好吧，也许这不是一条那么细的线。但它绝对是一条线。像大多数城市人一样，我从来没想过这个问题，它在哪里，它可能是什么，它可能由什么组成，直到塔玛拉和我前往一个农场。
[ROOSTER CROWS]
[公鸡打鸣]
I think that is the best one.
我认为那是最好的一张。
Yeah, we got to get him. We don't want him to get dirty or anything, do we? Or does it matter?
是的，我们得抓住它。我们不想让它弄脏什么的，对吧？或者这有关系吗？
She runs loose every day.
它每天都自由奔跑。
Can you find her?
你能找到它吗？
Yeah, we can pick her out.
是的，我们可以挑出它。
We're going to have to get them to-- we're going to have to wrangle them, you know.
我们需要让它们——我们需要围住它们，你知道。
We're at the Davidson's dairy farm, about an hour and a half Northwest of Chicago. Family members present, Paul, who's helping Tamara choose a bird to photograph, his sister Laura, who's studying photography at a nearby university, their grandfather, George Cairns, a veteran breeder, their father, Dick, who seems the most skeptical of this whole project, but who patiently shows Tamara and her assistant, Dennis, the milking barn as a possible place to set up and shoot.
我们在戴维森奶牛场，距离芝加哥西北约一个半小时路程。在场的家庭成员包括：保罗（Paul），他正在帮助塔玛拉挑选一只鸟来拍摄；他的妹妹劳拉（Laura），她在附近一所大学学习摄影；他们的祖父乔治·凯恩斯（George Cairns），一位资深的繁育者；他们的父亲迪克（Dick），他看起来对整个项目最怀疑，但他耐心地向塔玛拉和她的助手丹尼斯（Dennis）展示了挤奶棚作为一个可能的设置和拍摄场所。
What kind of an area are you looking for?
你在找什么样的区域？
Maybe-- it needs-- it could be a little wider, don't you think? If it could be from here to there and from that pole to that pole.
也许——它需要——它能再宽一点吗，你不觉得吗？如果能从这里到那里，从那根杆子到那根杆子就好了。
For what? I don't understand what--
为了什么？我不明白什么——
Well, we are setting-- maybe this is a good time to pull out the portfolio.
嗯，我们正在设置——也许现在是拿出作品集的好时机。
OK.
好的。
You want to grab it? I'm actually-- It's a study of the birds. But it's an isolated study so people aren't necessarily associating it with the farm and something to eat.
你想拿一下吗？我实际上是——这是对鸟类的研究。但这是一个孤立的研究，所以人们不一定会把它和农场以及食物联系起来。
Tamara takes us outside the barn, so dust won't get on her photos, and shows them her shots, name dropping the names of some big chicken people, people whose birds she's photographed, including Bob Wulff, editor of The Poultry Press. Dick notices that a bird in one photo has crooked toes.
塔玛拉带我们走出牛棚，以免灰尘弄到她的照片上，并给他们看了她的照片，随口提到了几个大鸡圈的名人，她拍过他们的鸟，包括《家禽新闻》（The Poultry Press）的编辑鲍勃·沃尔夫（Bob Wulff）。迪克注意到其中一张照片里的一只鸟脚趾是歪的。
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Well, probably on a hard surface. And they turn.
嗯，大概是在坚硬的表面上。它们就弯了。
What do you guys think of the pictures?
你们觉得这些照片怎么样？
Oh, the pictures are nice and sharp.
哦，照片又好又清晰。
[LAUGHS] There's nothing wrong with the pictures. If there's anything to find fault with, it's the birds. They aren't posing the way they should, some of them.
[笑声] 照片没什么问题。如果有什么可以挑剔的，那就是鸟。它们没有按照它们应该的方式摆姿势，其中一些。
Fact is, while city people usually go nuts when they see Tamara's pictures, a lot of chicken breeders don't like them. And to understand why, to fully comprehend this little culture clash here in America, we have to leave the barnyard for a minute and flashback to something that happened back at Tamara's apartment in the city.
事实是，虽然城市人看到塔玛拉的照片时通常会发疯，但很多养鸡的人并不喜欢它们。为了理解为什么，为了充分领会美国这小小的文化冲突，我们必须离开农家院一分钟，回到塔玛拉在城里的公寓里发生的事情。
Tamara showed me this old red book from the turn of the century, this book with the seal of the American Poultry Association in gold on the front, and then right there, in gold letters--
塔玛拉给我看了这本世纪之交的红色旧书，这本书的封面上印着美国家禽协会（American Poultry Association）的印章，是金色的，然后就在那里，用金字——
Standard of perfection. The standard of perfection is really the Bible of poultry standards, what birds are--
完美标准（Standard of perfection）。完美标准确实是家禽标准的圣经，鸟类是什么——
Tamara flipped past the engravings and illustrations of chickens of all types and breeds. These were show chickens, standing the way that chickens stand in competitions. Then Tamara pulled out one of her own photos to compare, to show me how her poses do not meet the standard in the book.
塔玛拉翻过了各种类型和品种的鸡的版画和插图。这些是展示鸡，以比赛中鸡站立的方式站立。然后塔玛拉拿出了她自己的一张照片进行对比，向我展示她的姿势是如何不符合书中的标准的。
The tail needs to be higher. Her feet are not erect, standing. Chest isn't out. Head, it needs to be up more. And it shows-- you can see the shape of the chicken much better in the standard-of-perfection pose.
尾巴需要更高。它的脚不是挺直站立的。胸部没有挺出来。头，它需要再往上一点。而且它展示了——你可以更好地看到鸡的形状，在完美标准的姿势下。
See, to me, what's so interesting, though, is that the standard of perfection doesn't include a personality.
看，对我来说，非常有趣的是，完美标准不包括个性。
Right. Because it's not about personality. It's about breeding.
对。因为它不是关于个性的。它是关于繁育的。
And so that is that a pose that the owners would want to own a photo of?
那么那是主人想要拥有的照片的姿势吗？
They're very particular about this. They want to see their bird in the standard-of-perfection pose, definitely, because that's what they've been taught, from 4-H, when they were kids, to do.
他们对此非常挑剔。他们当然想看到他们的鸟以完美标准的姿势出现，因为这是他们从小在4-H俱乐部学到的。
That's for them. For herself, for her city customers, she chooses the others. OK, back to the barnyard.
那是给他们看的。对于她自己，对于她的城市顾客，她选择其他的。好的，回到农家院。
[CHICKEN CLUCKING]
[鸡咯咯叫]
Tamara and the Davidsons decide to set up the photo session in a room that's usually used to store feed for the cows. It takes about 45 minutes to set this up. That 45 minutes includes dismantling and moving a wall of hay that is probably 10 feet high and 15 long. This takes five people. Then in comes the power and the fancy lights and the cloth backdrop that gets hung from a steel pole. The backdrop is ironed first with an iron and ironing board, brought from the city just for that purpose.
塔玛拉和戴维森一家决定在通常用来存放奶牛饲料的房间里进行拍照。设置这个需要大约45分钟。那45分钟包括拆除和移动一堵大约10英尺高、15英尺长的干草墙。这需要五个人。然后是电源、昂贵的灯光和用钢杆悬挂的布背景。背景首先用熨斗和熨衣板熨平，专门从城里带过来的。
11 and 1/2, 11, and an 8 and 1/2?
11.5，11，还有8.5？
Yeah, 11 and 1/2-- your test is going to be at 11 and 1/2, 11, and 8 and 1/2. I'm going to shoot your film at 11.
是的，11.5——你的测试将在11.5，11，和8.5。我要用11拍你的胶卷。
It was cold, well below freezing, so cold that the Polaroid film that Tamara uses for lighting tests would not fully develop.
天气很冷，远低于冰点，冷到塔玛拉用于灯光测试的宝丽来胶片无法完全显影。
Are you ready for the bird?
准备好要鸟了吗？
We're close. I just want to commune with the bird. We just want to make you pretty. Look how sweet, aren't you? You know what? I'm going to photograph you. My name is Tamara. I'll be your photographer for today.
我们快好了。我只想和这只鸟交流一下。我们只想让你变漂亮。看多可爱，不是吗？你知道吗？我要给你拍照。我叫塔玛拉。我今天会是你的摄影师。
Our first bird is a white Cornish, a show bird who belongs to George. The show bird is used to being picked up and handled. Part of preparing chickens for shows involves handling them a lot so they'll be calm with the judges.
我们的第一只鸟是一只白科尼什鸡（Cornish），属于乔治的展示鸡。这种展示鸡习惯于被捡起和处理。为展示准备鸡的部分工作包括多处理它们，这样它们在裁判面前会冷静。
If you could just nudge his head up a little bit, he's perfect. He's got his chest out. OK, now he's got his face in-- OK, yeah, you know what we want. Yeah, you're great, Georgie. He's got a feather on his back, here.
如果你能把它的头稍微往上推一点，它就完美了。它的胸部挺出来了。好的，现在它的脸进来了——好的，是的，你知道我们想要什么。是的，你太棒了，乔治（Georgie）。它的背上有根羽毛，这里。
Tamara has the Cornish stand up on a stack of little red antique books, kind of unsteady. Things go well for a while. She gets a half dozen good shots of the bird, expressive shots, more personality than standard of perfection, George tells me. The bird's chest isn't high enough. Its body is not turned correctly to the camera. And then the bird stops cooperating. He gets tired. Paul has a suggestion.
塔玛拉让科尼什鸡站在一摞红色古董小书上，有点不稳。事情顺利进行了一段时间。她拍到了半打好的鸟的照片，富有表现力的镜头，比完美标准更多的个性，乔治告诉我。鸟的胸部不够高。身体没有正确地转向镜头。然后那只鸟不再配合了。它累了。保罗有个建议。
Bring in a pullet.
带一只小母鸡进来。
You know what? You know that works.
你知道吗？你知道那是有用的。
Maybe you should explain what that is. What does that mean, to bring in a pullet?
也许你应该解释一下那是什么。带一只小母鸡进来是什么意思？
It takes, maybe, a female to perk them up.
这可能需要，雌性来提振它们。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Laura grabs a hen and waves at it the flaccid cock. The cock does not rise.
劳拉抓起一只母鸡，朝那只疲软的公鸡挥舞。公鸡没有站起来。
Come on, he's like, I'm just calm.
快点，它就像，我很冷静。
I can say that on the radio, right?
我可以在广播里说这个，对吧？
Laura, it probably would have been better to get the one from the other pen, that he's not used to.
劳拉，最好从另一个围栏里找一只它不习惯的，可能更好。
Fresh blood.
新鲜血液。
That looks nice.
看起来不错。
Bring him around a little bit, so his--
把它带过来一点，这样它的——
For real, the rooster will show off more for a hen that it doesn't know?
说真的，公鸡真的会为了它不认识的母鸡而炫耀吗？
Yes. If you put a new hen in with him or him in with a group of new hens, he will really show off.
是的。如果你放一只新母鸡和它在一起，或者把它放进一群新母鸡里，它真的会炫耀。
They try this and that, nothing with much success. Finally, with one shot left, Paul suggests putting a hen into the picture with the rooster.
他们尝试了这个和那个，没什么太大成功。最后，在只剩一张照片的时候，保罗建议在照片里放一只母鸡和公鸡在一起。
Now get the girl to-- she looks like her feet are so far apart, she's really struggling to stand.
现在让女孩去——她看起来脚分得那么开，她真的很努力地在站着。
That's the way they stand, though.
但它们就是那样站的。
They're wide apart.
它们分得很开。
That's all right. That's all right. Oh. Oh, did you see that?
没关系。没关系。哦。哦，你看到了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
All right--
好的——
Why? What did she just do? Describe.
为什么？她刚做了什么？描述一下。
She looked up at him very sweetly, like that, but with her head cocked. The male bird was posing. And she was posing also, but had a personality of just being the sweet, doting mother--
她很甜美地看着它，就像那样，但头歪着。雄鸟正在摆姿势。她也在摆姿势，但有一种只是作为甜美、溺爱母亲的个性——
But not standard of perfection?
但不符合完美标准？
But not standard of perfection. So we're done with this background and--
但不符合完美标准。所以我们拍完了这个背景，然后——
Not standard of perfection. Even these perfectly-bred Cornishes could not achieve standard of perfection today. And even in this goofy, unbirdlike situation, an hour of watching them makes clear just how hard it is to ever get birds to hit the standard, which is to say, not only do we completely dominate every aspect of the lives of chickens, their birth, their feed, their eggs, their slaughter, not only have we bred them to human specifications to meet human needs, but we have created a standard of what it means to be a chicken that most chickens can never meet.
不符合完美标准。即使是这些经过完美繁育的科尼什鸡今天也无法达到完美标准。即使在这种笨拙的、不像鸟的情况中，看它们一个小时也清楚地表明，让鸟达到标准是多么困难，也就是说，我们不仅完全支配了鸡生活的每一个方面，它们的出生、饲料、鸡蛋、屠宰，不仅我们根据人类需求繁育它们来满足人类需要，而且我们还创造了一个作为鸡的标准，大多数鸡永远无法达到。
That's what the standard means. We judge them as chickens. And we find them lacking. If they had the brains to understand this, they would be right to feel indignant.
这就是标准的含义。我们把它们作为鸡来判断。而我们发现它们缺乏这一点。如果它们有大脑来理解这一点，它们完全有权利感到愤慨。
But of course, this is a city person's perspective. And that means that it is completely wrongheaded from the point of view of anybody who actually raises birds. Standing in the cold feed room, I had a long, long talk with George about this. George is 80 years old. He's been raising birds since the-- I guess the Calvin Coolidge administration. And he says the whole fun of raising birds is raising them to the standard.
但这当然是城市人的视角。这意味着从任何真正养鸟的人的角度来看，这是完全错误的。站在寒冷的饲料室里，我和乔治谈了很久很久。乔治80岁了。我猜他从卡尔文·柯立芝（Calvin Coolidge）执政时期就开始养鸟了。他说养鸟的全部乐趣就是把它们养到标准。
Well, for instance, if your birds lack bone, OK, you go out and buy a bird as near to like them as you can with better bone. But when you mate them together, you might get long-legged birds or too short or-- you don't get what you want just by mating. It takes four or five years to gradually get it up. And by that, they're inbred and you need new ones.
嗯，例如，如果你的鸟缺乏骨骼，好的，你出去买一只尽可能像它们但骨骼更好的鸟。但当你把它们交配在一起时，你可能会得到长腿的鸟或太短的鸟——你不能仅仅通过交配就得到你想要的。需要四五年时间慢慢把它提上来。到那时，它们近亲繁殖了，你需要新的。
George tells me that when he's breeding a new batch of birds, he'll hatch 65 of them. And only one or two will be anywhere near the standard of perfection. That's how hard it is.
乔治告诉我，当他繁育一批新鸟时，他会孵化65只。只有一两只接近完美标准。这就是难度所在。
Do you get frustrated with the standard of perfection sometimes?
你有时会对完美标准感到沮丧吗？
No, we get frustrated with the judges, because every judge has his own idea of what the standard should be.
不，我们对裁判感到沮丧，因为每个裁判对标准应该是什么都有自己的想法。
I thought that's the whole point of a standard, is that the judge--
我以为这就是标准的全部意义，裁判——
That is. But one judge will want it this way and another, another. Today, if you've bred your birds to the standard perfection, weight and everything, and took them to the show, you probably wouldn't get anywhere. You got to breed to the fads.
确实。但一个裁判会想要这样，另一个会想要那样。今天，如果你按照完美标准，体重和一切繁育了你的鸟，带它们去参加比赛，你可能什么也得不到。你必须按潮流来繁育。
That's right, the fads, like Cornish's these days are supposed to have shorter legs than the real standard of perfection. Vertical tail feathers are out on all sorts of breeds that really should have them. In the country, among the chicken breeders, they think about a lot of things we never get to in the city.
没错，潮流，就像现在的科尼什鸡应该比真正的完美标准有更短的腿。直立的尾羽在各种本该有它们的品种中都不受欢迎。在乡下，在鸡繁育者中间，他们考虑了很多我们在城里永远不会想到的事情。
And when you're raising these birds, with any of these birds, do you have a close relationship with the bird the way some people would have with a pet?
当你繁育这些鸟时，对于任何这些鸟，你和它们有亲密关系吗，就像有些人对待宠物那样？
I don't have time. Yeah, I got too many things to do. See, three years ago, I almost died of cancer. And the good Lord told me how to cure myself. And so I've been working with that a lot, the last three years. I've been helping people, and put it in papers now. It's getting all over the United States.
我没时间。是的，我有太多事情要做。看，三年前，我差点死于癌症。仁慈的主告诉了我如何治愈自己。所以我过去三年一直在那上面投入很多精力。我一直在帮助人们，现在把它写在报纸上了。它正传遍美国。
What did you do? What do you do?
你做了什么？你做什么？
You used the root of a dandelion, simple as can be. But something in that that builds up your blood and your immune system.
你使用蒲公英的根，简单得不能再简单。但那里面有什么东西能建立你的血液和免疫系统。
Wait a second. You're saying that you were diagnosed with cancer, and this is the only treatment you had, and it cured you?
等一下。你是说你被诊断出患有癌症，这是你接受的唯一治疗，它治愈了你？
Yeah. And I've given it to other people when the medical world has told them that there's nothing more they can do. And they've got well too, but not all of them. If they're too far gone, it won't help them.
是的。当医学界告诉他们无能为力时，我也给了其他人。他们也康复了，但不是全部。如果他们病得太重，它就不会有帮助。
And you make it into tea or something like that?
你把它做成茶还是类似的东西？
Well, we just put it in little water or a little milk, Kool-Aid. You can put it on a sandwich, anything that isn't hot.
嗯，我们只是把它放在一点水、一点牛奶、酷爱饮料（Kool-Aid）里。你可以把它放在三明治上，任何不热的东西。
George gives me a pamphlet that he's written up. No doctor has actually checked him out to prove the cancer is gone from his body. He's actually got no hard, scientific proof that this really works. But he says God told him that this is the way he should be spending his time. And it has cut into his bird breeding a bit.
乔治给了我一本他写的小册子。没有医生真正检查过他以证明他体内的癌症消失了。他实际上没有任何确凿的科学证据证明这真的管用。但他说上帝告诉他这是他应该花时间的方式。这确实对他的养鸟造成了一点影响。
George leaves, off on other business. Tamara's finished hanging and lighting the next backdrop. And the rest of us begin with the second bird, a bird called a Brahma, with elaborately patterned brown-and-white feathers.
乔治离开了，去做其他事了。塔玛拉完成了挂起和打光下一个背景。我们其他人开始了第二只鸟，一种叫做婆罗门鸡（Brahma）的鸟，有着精心图案的棕白色羽毛。
[CHICKEN CLUCKS]
[鸡咯咯叫]
Got her.
抓到她了。
She is big.
她很大。
Yep.
是的。
This is a chicken like the size of a dog.
这鸡大得像条狗。
Not that big.
没那么大。
A small dog.
一条小狗。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Our second bird demonstrates the great distance between bird instinct and intelligence and the demands of modern fashion photography, which is to say of civilization. Called upon to do human tasks, even rather passive ones, a bird remains a bird. Paul carries the huge hen onto the fragile little set Tamara's built.
我们的第二只鸟展示了鸟的本能和智力与现代时尚摄影的需求（即文明的需求）之间的巨大距离。被要求执行人类任务，即使是相当被动的任务，鸟仍然是鸟。保罗把那只巨大的母鸡抬到了塔玛拉搭建的脆弱小舞台上。
He's a beauty. What are you eating there, buddy?
它真是个美人。你在吃什么，伙计？
[CLUCKING]
[咯咯叫]
Whoa.
哇。
Ooh, it slapped me.
哦，它打了我。
I'm scared of this one, she says quietly, as she adjusts her camera. The chicken is so big, nine pounds, the size of a small consumer turkey, that she has to pull the camera back. The Davidsons are looking at her skeptically. Paul asks pointedly if she's ever shot a bird this big?
我害怕这一只，她低声说，边调整相机。这只鸡太大了，9磅，像只小型食用火鸡，她不得不把相机往后拉。戴维森一家怀疑地看着她。保罗尖锐地问她是否拍过这么大的鸟？
We've got to figure out where the--
我们得找出——
[CLUCKING]
[咯咯叫]
Whoa.
哇。
Hello, bird. Are you going to slap me in the face again? I hope not.
你好，鸟。你还要再打我的脸吗？我希望不要。
These hens will jump right in your face.
这些母鸡会跳到你的脸上。
You know why you're here? Let's talk. We need you to be beautiful. Here's your moment. OK? There are more where you came from, buddy. You better act up, here.
你知道你为什么在这吗？让我们谈谈。我们需要你变漂亮。这是你的时刻。好吗？伙计，你还有很多伙伴。你最好表现好点。
This combination of coddling and threats might motivate an aspiring supermodel or an eager puppy. But this, after all, is a chicken. Laura tries to lure it up with a handful of corn.
这种宠爱和威胁的结合可能会激励一个雄心勃勃的超模或一只渴望的小狗。但这毕竟是一只鸡。劳拉试着用一把玉米把它引诱上来。
Is she standing?
她站着吗？
She can get corn-- or she's trying to get it. But she has to stand up high for it.
她能得到玉米——或者她正在试图得到它。但她必须站得很高才能得到。
Is that what you want her to stand?
这就是你想要她站的地方吗？
Somewhere during this ordeal, a funny thing happens. All the Davidsons, who all started off skeptical, they are completely engaged. Dick suggests a pose that is pure art concept, a pose that could not be further from standard of perfection. Laura lures the bird with corn. Paul smooths feathers. And when the bird quivers or moves a wing, three people jump in to fix it back up.
在这场折磨的某个过程中，发生了一件有趣的事。所有一开始持怀疑态度的戴维森一家，都完全参与进来了。迪克提出了一个纯艺术概念的姿势，一个离完美标准再远不过的姿势。劳拉用玉米诱惑鸟。保罗梳理羽毛。当鸟颤抖或移动翅膀时，三个人跳进去把它修补好。
There's some feathers on the breast a little bit fluffy. It's like she's not real clean down there. OK. She's a little farther. You guys are a great team. I'm going to hire you to come with me.
胸部的羽毛有点蓬松。看起来她在那下面不是很干净。好的。她离得远一点。你们是一个很棒的团队。我要雇你们和我一起去。
[SHUTTER CLICKS]
[快门声]
Oops. I got a hand in there. That's my-- move the hand. Move the hand. Move the hand. OK, great.
哎呀。我把手弄进去了。那是我的——移开手。移开手。移开手。好的，太棒了。
It wasn't until this point that I realized that I came into this expecting the bird to be more-- well, more human, partly I think because I never really thought about this one way or the other but partly because Tamara's photos make chickens seem so-- [INHALES, EXHALES] so thoughtful.
直到这一点我才意识到，我来这里时以为这只鸟会更——好吧，更像人，部分原因我认为因为我从没真的想过这一面或另一面，但部分原因是因为塔玛拉的照片让鸡看起来——[吸气，呼气] 那么沉思。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Over here. Look at the cameras. Look at the camera.
这边。看相机。看相机。
Now she's completely out of frame.
现在她完全不在画面里了。
Those photos are a lie.
那些照片是谎言。
Hello.
你好。
I think you're going to have a one-shot opportunity here. It's going to be when I let go.
我想你这里只有一次机会。那就是我松手的时候。
[CHICKEN CLUCKING]
[鸡咯咯叫]
Jeez, I didn't even let go. I just started to let up. And he yanked it right out of my hand.
天哪，我甚至还没松手。我只是开始放松。它就直接从我手里扯出来了。
Fact is, you can try to give chickens respect. You can try to treat them with dignity, and photograph them the way you'd photograph anything or anyone that's serious. But the chickens will not care. You can make them look dignified. But it is a brainless, bird-like dignity. And it is ephemeral.
事实是，你可以尝试给予鸡尊重。你可以尝试用尊严对待它们，像拍任何认真对待的东西或人一样拍它们。但鸡不会在乎。你可以让它们看起来很威严。但这是一种无脑的、像鸟一样的尊严。它是短暂的。
Do you feel like your relationship with chicken has changed because of this?
你觉得你和鸡的关系因为这个而改变了吗？
No. Not at all.
不。完全没有。
How could that not be so?
怎么可能不是这样呢？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Gosh. I order the chicken when I'm at the show. I eat it right in front of the chickens.
天哪。我在展览时点鸡肉吃。我就在鸡面前吃它。
You eat chicken while you're standing there with a chicken?
你站在这只鸡旁边时吃鸡肉？
Yes. [LAUGHS] Is it wrong? I don't know. I'm hungry.
是的。[笑声] 这错吗？我不知道。我饿了。
Well, no wonder they won't sit still.
嗯，怪不得它们不坐好。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah.
是的。
[FRANTIC CLUCKING]
[狂乱的咯咯声]
We pack up our gear and move the massive wall of hay back into place. As we do this, chickens hop by, Brahmas, Americanos, mixed breeds. They seem utterly uninterested in us. The cluck at each other. There's feed to eat, hay to nestle in. They have better things to do with their time. And there's nothing that makes you realize just how inhuman chickens are then spending a day trying to make them seem human.
我们收拾好装备，把那堵巨大的干草墙放回原处。当我们这样做时，鸡跳来跳去，婆罗门鸡、美国鸡、混种。它们似乎对我们完全没兴趣。互相咯咯叫。有饲料要吃，有干草要钻。它们有更有意义的事情要做。没有什么比花一天时间试图让鸡看起来像人更能让你意识到鸡是多么非人。
[CHICKENS CLUCKING]
[鸡咯咯叫]
[COW MOOS]
[奶牛哞哞叫]
Act 4, Winged Migration.
第四幕，迁徙的翅膀。
So it was Saturday, January 10, 2004. And Spalding was in our apartment, in New York, with our daughter, Marissa, who was 16 at the time, and Theo, who was six.
那是2004年1月10日，星期六。斯伯丁（Spalding）在我们纽约的公寓里，和我们16岁的女儿玛丽莎（Marissa），还有6岁的西奥（Theo）在一起。
This is Kathie Russo. Her husband was Spalding Gray, who is best known for delivering monologues on stage, like Monster in a Box and Swimming to Cambodia. Both those monologues were also filmed as movies.
这是凯西·拉索（Kathie Russo）。她的丈夫是斯伯丁·格雷（Spalding Gray），他以在舞台上表演独角戏而闻名，如《箱中怪物》（Monster in a Box）和《游泳去柬埔寨》（Swimming to Cambodia）。这两部独角戏也被拍成了电影。
Spalding Gray went missing on January 10, 2004. Witnesses say they saw him on the Staten Island Ferry that night. His body was finally found, pulled out of the East River two months later. Our program today is about birds and the hold they have on us. And Kathie Russo tells the story about Spalding's last night and the days immediately after that.
斯伯丁·格雷于2004年1月10日失踪。目击者称当晚看到他在史泰登岛轮渡上。他的尸体最终在两个月后从东河被捞出。我们今天的节目是关于鸟类以及它们对我们的吸引力。凯西·拉索讲述了斯伯丁最后一晚以及随后的日子的故事。
Like she just said, her husband was with two of their kids that night. She was out. They have a third child, Forrest, who was 11 at the time. He was in Sag Harbor, Long Island, with friends and a babysitter. They had a house out there too.
正如她刚才所说，那天晚上她的丈夫和他们的两个孩子在一起。她出去了。他们有第三个孩子，福雷斯特（Forrest），当时11岁。他当时在长岛的萨格港（Sag Harbor），和朋友以及保姆在一起。他们在那里也有个房子。
Spalding had had dinner with the kids. And then it got to be about 7:00 PM. He said he was going to meet an old friend. And Marissa goes, oh, that's fine. I'm here. I can watch Theo. And he went out. And about an hour and a half after that, he called to check in on the kids. Theo answered. And he said, how's everything going? He goes, good. He goes, well, I love you very much and I'll be home soon. And we never saw Spalding again.
斯伯丁和孩子们一起吃了晚饭。然后大约是晚上7点。他说他要去见一个老朋友。玛丽莎说，哦，那很好。我在家。我可以照顾西奥。于是他出去了。大约一个半小时后，他打电话来关心孩子们。西奥接了电话。他说，一切都好吗？他说，好。他说，嗯，我非常爱你，我会很快回家的。我们就再也没有见过斯伯丁。
The next series of events still seem like a blur to me, even five years later. But the first thing I had to do was go report Spalding missing. I did that. And then I decided to send the kids home, back to Sag Harbor, to join their brother. So I stayed for two days, did whatever I could, which was pretty much nothing. And after two days, I just decided, I'm going back to Sag Harbor to join all the kids.
接下来的一系列事件即使在五年后对我来说仍然像一场模糊。但我必须做的第一件事是去报告斯伯丁失踪。我做了。然后我决定让孩子们回家，回到萨格港，去和他们的兄弟汇合。所以我留了两天，做了我能做的任何事，也就是几乎什么都没做。两天后，我决定，我要回萨格港去和所有的孩子汇合。
So I'm driving on the Long Island Expressway, back to Sag Harbor. And I get a phone call on my cell phone. And it was Theo. And he was all excited. And he said, Mom, Mom, we came home today from school, and there was a bird, a little bird, flying around the island in the kitchen.
我在长岛高速公路上开车，回萨格港。我的手机响了。是西奥。他非常兴奋。他说，妈妈，妈妈，我们今天放学回家，有一只鸟，一只小鸟，在厨房岛上飞来飞去。
I said, and then what did you do next? And he said, well, we followed the bird. And Marissa followed him into the bathroom. And she tried to calm the bird. And she took a hat and cupped it over the bird and captured the bird and went outside and let him out free. And I was just so dumbfounded and awestruck.
我说，然后你们接下来做了什么？他说，嗯，我们跟着那只鸟。玛丽莎跟着它进了浴室。她试图让鸟安静下来。她拿了一顶帽子扣在鸟身上，抓住了鸟，走到外面让它自由飞走。我当时真是目瞪口呆，心生敬畏。
The first image that came to my head, when he said that there was something-- a bird, in particular, circling over this island-- was I thought of Spalding and how for the last two years, he had obsessively circled around that island, talking to himself, just circling and in total anguish.
当他说有一只鸟，特别是，在这个岛屿上盘旋时，我脑海中浮现的第一个形象——我想到斯伯丁，以及过去两年他如何痴迷地围着那个岛盘旋，自言自语，只是在痛苦中盘旋。
You see, two years before that, we had been in Ireland, celebrating his 60th birthday. And the second day there, Spalding and I were in a horrible car accident. Spalding suffered enormous head trauma. He was never the same.
你看，在那之前的两年，我们一直在爱尔兰庆祝他的60岁生日。在那里的第二天，斯伯丁和我发生了一场可怕的车祸。斯伯丁遭受了巨大的头部创伤。他再也不是以前那个人了。
They actually had to put titanium plate in his head. He was in and out of hospitals for two years after the accident. Doctors prescribed various cocktails of pills for him. Nothing worked, not even the 20 electric-shock treatments that he had.
他们实际上不得不把钛板放进他的脑袋里。车祸后他断断续续在医院住了两年。医生为他开了各种药片组合。什么都没用，即使是他接受的20次电击治疗也没用。
And the second thought I had, when I heard about the bird was, was this a message from Spalding? Was he trying to tell us something? We've never had a bird in our house before. And I remember the Irish have this saying that if you find a bird in your house after someone dies, and it's alive, the person's soul is free. And if you find a dead bird, the person's soul is restless.
当我听说这只鸟时，我想到的第二个念头是，这是斯伯丁发来的信息吗？他是在试图告诉我们什么吗？我们以前从来没有养过鸟。我记得爱尔兰人有句俗话，如果有人死后你在家里发现一只鸟，而且它还活着，那个人的灵魂就是自由的。如果你发现一只死鸟，那个人的灵魂就是不安的。
And I remember Spalding-- I'll never forget the story-- after his mother killed herself 35 years before, his father woke up the very next day, and next to his bed, where his slippers were on the floor, was a dead bird. And that story just stayed with me.
我记得斯伯丁——我永远不会忘记这个故事——在他母亲35年前自杀后，他父亲第二天醒来，在他床边地板上放拖鞋的地方，是一只死鸟。那个故事就一直留在我的脑海里。
So that night, after the kids went to bed, I went around the house, and I was making sure that another bird could not get into this house because I wasn't going to take the chance of another bird coming into the house and dying. So I checked all the windows and I closed all the fireplaces to make sure, to guarantee, that there was no way a bird could come into our house.
所以那天晚上，孩子们睡着后，我绕着房子走，确保没有另一只鸟能进到这房子里，因为我不打算冒另一只鸟进来死掉的风险。所以我检查了所有的窗户，关闭了所有的壁炉，以确保，保证，没有办法让一只鸟进到我们的房子里。
And the next day, I was at the dining-room table, reading the paper. And I looked up. And there was a bird across the table, peering at me. And I just couldn't believe what I was seeing. So I yell out to the kids, who were in the other room. And they run in, and the bird takes off and flies up the stairs. And we all follow it.
第二天，我坐在餐桌旁读报纸。我抬头看。桌子对面有一只鸟，盯着我。我简直不敢相信我看到的一切。于是我朝在另一个房间里的孩子们大喊。他们跑进来，鸟起飞飞上了楼梯。我们都跟着它。
And it goes into what's our office. And it's perched on top of this window. And I shut the door behind me. And for some reason, I held up my hands, thinking the bird might magically come to my hands. And I go, Spalding, it's OK. You're safe now. It's OK. Come to me.
它进了我们的办公室。它栖息在那扇窗户的顶部。我在身后关上了门。不知为什么，我举起双手，心想鸟儿可能会神奇地飞到我的手上。我说，斯伯丁，没事的。你现在安全了。没事的。到我这里来。
And Forrest and Theo are on the other side of the door going, Mom, why are you calling the bird after Dad? And the bird just sat there, staring at me. And then it took off. And it flew over my hands. And in between the space in between the door and the floor, it scooted out, went past the boys, flew down the stairs-- and we had already opened up the kitchen doors-- and it flew out the kitchen doors. And it was safe. And it was gone.
福雷斯特和西奥在门的那边说，妈妈，你为什么在爸失踪后叫那只鸟？那只鸟只是坐在那里盯着我。然后它起飞了。它飞过我的手。在门和地板之间的空间里，它窜了出去，从男孩们身边经过，飞下楼梯——我们已经打开了厨房的门——它飞出了厨房的门。它安全了。它不见了。
The next day, I'm in the kitchen. And Forrest calls out from the TV room-- he was watching cartoons. He goes, Mom, the bird's back. It's at the end of the couch. So before I even go into the room, I open up the kitchen doors just to make sure we have an exit for the bird. And I run into the family room. And sure enough, there's the bird.
第二天，我在厨房里。福雷斯特从电视室喊道——他在看卡通片。他说，妈妈，鸟又回来了。在沙发末端。所以我在进房间前就打开了厨房的门，确保我们有一条鸟的出口。我跑到家庭室。果然，鸟在那里。
And it's become a drill now. This is the third day, consecutive day, with the bird in our house. And we follow the bird around. And this time, it goes through the living room. And then it comes back into the kitchen. And I actually got the camera out. And I took a picture of it. And the bird flew out. Just like that, it was gone. And two months later, they found Spalding's body in the East River.
现在这已经成了一种例行公事了。这是鸟在我们家里连续的第三天了。我们跟着鸟到处走。这一次，它穿过客厅。然后它回到厨房。我真的拿出相机。我给它拍了张照片。鸟飞走了。就像那样，它不见了。两个月后，他们在东河发现了斯伯丁的尸体。
I think with suicide in particular, it's a really hard death to digest. There's a lot of guilt. You go back and back, and you get into that mode of, I should have done this, I could have done that. It's a seesaw of guilt and forgiveness.
我认为自杀尤其是一种很难消化的死亡。有很多内疚。你不断地回想，你进入了那种模式：我本该做这个，我可以做那个。这是一个内疚与宽恕的跷跷板。
So last year was my 47th birthday. And I was feeling blue. And I was really missing Spalding. And I went on this bike route that the two of us used to take together. And it ends up by the water. And just before I got to the water, I saw this little brownish-gray bird sitting on the side of the road, just like the one that we had in our house.
所以去年是我47岁生日。我感到忧郁。我非常想念斯伯丁。我骑上了我们俩曾经一起走过的自行车路线。它最终靠近水边。就在我到达水边之前，我看到这只褐色的小鸟坐在路边，就像我们屋里的那只一样。
And I passed by it on my bike. I ride pretty fast. But something told me, go back. And I did. And the bird was just sitting there. And I'd get up close to it, and didn't fly away. So I figured the bird was hurt.
我骑自行车经过它。我骑得很快。但有什么东西告诉我，回去。我回去了。那只鸟只是坐在那里。我靠近它，它没有飞走。所以我想这只鸟受伤了。
And I'm looking at the bird, crouching over it. And this jogger goes by me, and he said, oh, that bird was there two hours ago when I started my run. So I raced back home on my bike. And I went into the house and I collected a shoe box and I filled it with grass and birdseed, got some rubber gloves.
我看着鸟，蹲在它上面。那个慢跑的人经过我身边，他说，哦，那只鸟两个小时前我开始跑步时就在那里了。所以我骑车飞奔回家。我进屋拿了一个鞋盒，往里装满草和鸟食，拿了一副橡胶手套。
And I drove back to where the bird was. And the bird was still there. It was about a mile from my house. And it's just looking up at me. So I thought it was really hurt. And I tried to scoop it into the shoe box. And it just gets up, looks at me, and flies away. There's nothing wrong with it. Wings were fine. I saw it flying off into the distance.
我开车回到那只鸟所在的地方。那只鸟还在那里。离我家大约一英里。它只是抬头看着我。所以我以为它真的受伤了。我试图把它铲进鞋盒。它只是站起来，看着我，飞走了。它一点事也没有。翅膀很好。我看着它飞向远方。
And I thought-- it just hit me like a ton of bricks, right at that moment, there was nothing I could do to save this innocent little bird, which in the end, he was fine. He flew away. And there was nothing I could do to save Spalding.
我想——就在那一刻，它像砖头一样重重地撞击着我，我没有什么能做的来拯救这只天真的小鸟，它最终，它很好。它飞走了。而没有什么我能做的来拯救斯伯丁。
Kathie Russo, these days she's a producer on the podcast, You and Me Both with Hillary Clinton and the executive producer of the podcast Here's the Thing with Alec Baldwin.
凯西·拉索，这些天她是希拉里·克林顿（Hillary Clinton）播客《你和我》（You and Me Both）的制作人，也是亚历克·鲍德温（Alec Baldwin）播客《就是这样》（Here's the Thing）的执行制片人。
Well, the various stories in today's rerun were produced by Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Blue Chevigny, Jane Marie, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alyssa Shipp, Julie Snyder, Alix Spiegel, and Nancy Updike.
嗯，今天重播中的各个故事是由亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、蓝·切维尼（Blue Chevigny）、简·玛丽（Jane Marie）、萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alyssa Shipp）、朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）制作的。
Music help from Mr. John Conners. Other help today from Larry Josephson and Jay [? Headblade. ?] Additional production on today's rerun from James Bennett II, Michael Cromartie, and Stowe Nelson.
音乐帮助来自约翰·康纳斯先生（Mr. John Conners）。今天其他的帮助来自拉里·约瑟夫森（Larry Josephson）和杰伊·海德布雷德（Jay Headblade）。今天重播的额外制作来自詹姆斯·贝内特二世（James Bennett II）、迈克尔·克罗马蒂（Michael Cromartie）和斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）。
Some updates on the people in today's rerun. Tamara Staples has launched a Kickstarter campaign for a new project, a documentary series about show chickens. It's called The Standard Of Perfection. George Cairns, the grandfather from the Davidson's dairy farm, died back in 2011.
关于今天重播中人物的一些更新。塔玛拉·斯台普斯发起了一个Kickstarter众筹活动，用于一个新项目，一个关于展示鸡的纪录片系列。它叫《完美标准》（The Standard Of Perfection）。戴维森奶牛场的祖父乔治·凯恩斯已于2011年去世。
Susan Vitucci's opera about Chicken Little is available on CD and also on several streaming platforms. More information on where you can find it at www.pulcina.org. That is Pulcina spelled, of course, P-U-L-C-I-N-A. [INAUDIBLE] story about her first aired all the way back in 1997.
苏珊·维图奇关于小鸡快跑的歌剧在CD和几个流媒体平台上都有提供。更多关于你在哪里可以找到它的信息，请访问www.pulcina.org。当然，Pulcina的拼写是P-U-L-C-I-N-A。[听不清] 关于她的故事最早在1997年播出。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream over 800 of our episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's merch for your holiday shopping. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，你可以完全免费播放我们800多集的剧集。此外，还有供你节日购物的周边商品。《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know what product drives him crazy? Chicken of the Sea. He's like, it's not chicken. It's tuna. Typical that a tuna would fib like that. Chicken never would.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创办人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）。你知道什么产品让他发疯吗？“海中鸡”（Chicken of the Sea）。他总是说，那不是鸡。那是金枪鱼。一条金枪鱼会撒谎，真是典型。鸡才不会。
Chickens aren't going to lie. Chickens have integrity.
鸡是不会撒谎的。鸡有诚信。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。